à l'aéroport de yerevan des dizaines de
vols atterrissent chaque jour rempli de
russan fuite à l'arrivée c'est le
soulagement
[Musique]
depuis qu'ils sont en arménie ces jeunes
moscovites se sentent en sécurité mais
reste inquiet pour l'avenir de leur pays
d'après avez des infos plus de 14 mille
manifestants ont été interpellés pour
avoir protesté contre l'invasion nous
sommes
pour ceux qui ont fui la peur se mêle à
la culpabilité
[Musique]
habitué des manifestations contre le
gouvernement lève et son père ont été
arrêtées l'année dernière désormais
protesté leur semble inutile
pour la plupart de leurs moyens de
paiement sont bloqués et tous vont
bientôt perdre leur emploi leurs
perspectives en arménie sont minces un
seul espoir pour la suite
vienne dow jones jim
hendry
dans cet environnement plus paisibles
ces russes avoue ne pas savoir comment
se définir entre touristes et réfugiés
politiques